bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
bienvenue dans ce sens public 90 minutes
de débat de reportages et d' expertise
comme tous les soirs sur public sénat la
promesse est dans le titre donner du
sens à l'actualité se mettre au service
des citoyens vous proposer des clés de
compréhension des enjeux de cette
campagne présidentielle voici le
sommaire de ce 21 février
c'est la guerre des nerfs en ukraine un
sommet byden poutine annoncé par
l'elysée puis jugée prématurée par
moscou des bombardements d heures d
images manipuler le conflit est il
inévitable je poserai la question à mes
invités dans une minute
comment accueillir les enfants
handicapés à l'école 14 janvier dernier
le candidat zemmour fustigé je cite
l'obsession de l'inclusion et voulait
les cantonner dans des établissements
spécialisés au delà de la polémique loin
des récupérations politiques les parents
les accompagnants et les profs ouvre
l'horizon de ses élèves au portage à
marseille tout à l'heure et puis les
candidates et les candidats plancher
face au medef aujourd'hui comment mieux
distribuer les profits des entreprises
alors que le pouvoir d'achat est plus
que jamais la première préoccupation des
électeurs on débattra sur le partage de
la valeur dans le second débat de notre
émission
mais d'abord donc ce sommet poutine by
dunk emmanuel macron semblait avoir
arraché la bonne nouvelle que nous avons
découvert au réveil il n'aura pas tenu
jusqu'au déjeuner pascal flamand ne
gaspard flamand par la possibilité d'un
sommet entre joe biden et vladimir
poutine proposé par emmanuel macron a
suscité beaucoup d'attentes mais semble
s'éloigner les espoirs ont été
rapidement douchés par le kremlin qui
juge prématuré la tenue d'une telle
réunion
l'utilisation de l'ukraine comme
instrument de confrontation avec notre
pays représente une menace sérieuse très
grande pour nous
sur le terrain la situation est loin de
s'apaiser la russie et l'ukraine
s'accusent mutuellement d'être
responsables des provocations et
bombardements dans l'est séparatistes du
pays pour kiev l'union européenne doit
agir et envisager des sanctions pour
désamorcer la situation nous pensons
qu'il existe de bonnes raisons de bonnes
et légitime eu raison d'imposer au moins
certaines des sanctions maintenant afin
de démontrer que l'union européenne ne
se contente pas de parler de sanctions
mais qu'elle suit également la marche à
suivre
depuis plusieurs semaines la russie
affirme qu'elle ne prévoit pas
d'invasion de l'ukraine pourtant ces
images satellites américaine montre des
mouvements de troupe et d'équipements
militaires russes près de la frontière
ukrainienne avec l'intensification des
combats dans l'est du pays ces derniers
jours les séparatistes pro russes
appellent poutine à reconnaître leur
indépendance une réponse du kremlin doit
être donnée très prochainement côté
occidental on craint toujours une
attaque russe imminente few days il y a
quelques jours leurs déclarations
offrait une très petite lueur d'espoir
mais leurs actions prennent la forme
d'un renforcement militaire continue
avec de graves incidents dans le donbass
minutes mais nous ne pouvons pas
éternellement offrir un rameau d'olivier
alors que la russie a effectué des tests
de missiles et continue d'amasser des
trophées à nolife bref les réunions
diplomatiques vont se poursuivre dans la
semaine l'ukraine demande une réunion
d'urgence du conseil de sécurité de
l'onu de son côté le ministre russe des
affaires étrangères va rencontrer son
homologue américain jeudi puis français
vendredi
et pour mieux comprendre cette guerre
des nerfs j'accueille pascal boniface
bonsoir bien soin vous êtes directeur
fondateur de l'institut de relations
internationales et stratégiques vous
publiez 50 idées reçues sur l'état du
monde c'est aux éditions armand colin
galia ackerman bonsoir vous êtes
historienne journaliste spécialiste de
la russie et de l'espace postsoviétique
votre livre le régiment immortel la
guerre sacrée de poutine c'est aux
éditions premier parallèle patrick
martin geniez bonsoir bienvenue à vous
aussi enseignant à sciences po paris
spécialiste des questions européennes et
vous publiez vers une nouvelle
gouvernance mondiale aux éditions
studyrama jacques également mathieu
croissandeau éditorialiste politique
bonsoir mathieu dans ce sens avec moi
toute la semaine et à la fin vous y
faire lundi mardi mercredi jeudi moi
aussi alors je commence sur pourront
dire sur le sujet de gaspard flamand ce
sommet byden poutine pascal boniface est
ce que vous diriez que le prélat public
et est tombé dans une sorte de piège qui
s'est piégé lui-même en annonçant cette
nouvelle un peu trop tôt au milieu de la
nuit où il est possible qu'ils en aient
parlé on sent les clés vraiment poutine
mais que poutine ne peut être pas
apprécié que mails m'apprend s'accapare
ce succès qui n'a pas voulu livrer ce
cadeau peut-être que ce sommet aura lieu
mais il aura lieu si poutine des signes
qu'il aura lieu et non pas si macron
devient un peu le grand triomphateur qui
réunit le prisons américaines évoluent
donc je pense que le scénario le plus
probable c'est que ça a été évoqué c'est
une piste sérieuse et on sait que
boudinés désireux de parler byden parce
que pour lui c'est une reconnaissance
est de parler sur un pied d'égalité
alors que le statut des deux pays n'est
plus le même en terme de puissance un
bon mais en même temps il n'aime pas que
donner le sentiment qu'on lui dit sa
conduite et qu'il n'est pas maître des
horloges galia ackerman vous en avez
fait un débat sur sur la situation en
ukraine ya quelques semaines vous nous
aviez dit qu'il fallait jamais perdre de
vue que vladimir poutine s'adresse
d'abord à son opinion
public est-ce que c'est toujours vrai
aujourd'hui où est-ce que c'est plus
large que ça d'une certaine façon je
crois que c'est peut-être même plus vrai
que jamais parce que ce sommet
d'ailleurs byden poutine peut être ne
sera d'aucune actualité vous savez
certainement qu'il ya très récemment la
douma a voté unanimement la
reconnaissance la demande adressée à un
appel au président poutine de
reconnaître l'indépendance des deux
républiques séparatistes des nerfs et
les nerfs donc de donetsk est lougansk
et poutine il ya quelques jours et la
diable on va voir peut-être il faut
utiliser les possibilités de l'accord du
maire de minsk mais en même temps cette
idée fait son chemin aujourd'hui une
reconnaissance de l'indépendance des
deux républiques séparatistes voilà
aujourd'hui
les dirigeants de ces deux républiques
ont solennellement appelé
poutine à reconnaître des républiques il
ya eu déjà la réunion du conseil de
sécurité aussi aujourd'hui les membres
du conseil de sécurité ont unanimement
reconnu la nécessité de cette
reconnaissance le premier ministre russe
a demandé aussi de reconnaître ces
républiques il a dit qu'il travaillait
pendant quelques mois déjà à la
reconnaissance et à l'amortissement des
sanctions à venir poutine doit donner sa
décision ce soir il me semble aux yeux
de tous que je viens d'énoncer que c'est
cette décision est déjà prise maintenant
il ya une nuance donetsk est lougansk
c'est un tiers des régions
administratives de deux au bled de
donetsk et de lula mais alors pour
comprendre pas d'en interrompre si
effectivement
bruening ne reconnaît l'indépendance de
ces deux territoires qui c'est quoi
c'est un pas supplémentaire selon vous
vers la guerre ça veut dire quoi non
probablement pas parce que je pense que
les ukrainiens ne feront pas la guerre
pour pour cela en deux manches le
ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur kolokoltsev a souligné pendant
la réunion du conseil de sécurité que il
faut reconnaître ces deux territoires
dans les frontières administratives ce
que j'ai commencé à dire les frontières
administratives
c'est les républiques actuellement
occupe un tiers seulement de ses
frontières administratives donc il peut
y avoir une guerre local pour
établir
les fronts tiendra effectivement
quelques l ampleur
cette invasion pour répondre je reviens
vers vous tout à l'heure et je voudrais
vous entendre là patrick martin je n'y
ai effectivement pascal boniface l'un
peut aborder dans le dans la stratégie
d'un vladimir poutine il ya aussi la
volonté de se replacer au centre de
l'échiquier diplomatique ça on peut dire
que il y est depuis depuis quelques
jours voire quelques semaines et il y
est manifestement dans le mauvais sens
mais il y occupe la scène internationale
et stratégique
mais il a dit quelque chose qui était
tout à fait intéressant il ya quelques
semaines il est même et quelques jours
et nous nous voulons que la russie soit
respectée donc il considère que tu paies
d'écoulement d'union soviétique son pays
n'est plus respectée il a vécu comme un
drame l'écroulement de l'union
soviétique et lui finalement beaucoup
dénoncent une politique néo impérialiste
de reconstitution d'une sorte de classe
de 2de glacis d'état tempe ou qui sont
là effectivement pour reconstituer la
protection autour de la russie tant
qu'il est au centre de cet échiquier il
est tellement au centre d'ailleurs qu'il
a des lignes rouges et des exigences
tout à fait recevable de la part de
l'otan notamment retiré des chats
retirer les forces de l'otan de certains
pays de l'est tels que la pologne la
roumanie ou la bulgarie tous ces pays
qui sera coté du bélarus aussi tout ça
et s'engager à ce que l'ukraine d'entre
eux jamais dans l'otan alors
premièrement oui tout à fait il ya ça
aussi mais sur ce point on peut dire
qu'il a presque gagné 1 parce que de
toute façon aux termes de l'article 10
du de la charte de l'otan il faut
l'unanimité pour qu'apple entre dans le
temps lorsque vous voyez que la chose
chancelier lorsqu'il est allé à moscou a
dit mais pourquoi se disputer sur un
sujet qui n'est pas sur la table puisque
en fin de compte ça veut dire que
l'ukraine ne viendra pas dans l'otan et
on a même parlé d'une phalange nisation
sa fermentation pardon c'est à dire une
neutralisation pas de ce pays comme la
finlande l'a vécu pendant la guerre
froide ans qu'il est au centre il a
obtenu effectivement satisfaction sur le
fait que l'udc reda n'intégrerait pas
l'otan il souhaite avoir a traité sur
les armements du côté de l'est et enfin
effectivement comme cela vient d'être
dit et ils sont sur le point de
reconnaître les républiques séparatistes
ce qui serait tout de même un pas
supplémentaire dans la violation du
droit international
alors la question principale on va dire
de ce débat pascal boniface et c'est
peut-être pas si facile qui répond
évidemment c'est bien été inévitable
c'est un peu l'impression qu'on a quand
on est moins spécialistes que vous petit
pas par petit pas qu on y va tout droit
est ce que vous puis d'un mois qu'on
l'annonçant elle aussi dénoncé un coup
d'état et qui allait renverser le prix
danse hélène skis et maître une potiche
pro-poutine à sa place n'est pas
survenue la guerre devait éclater
mercredi dernier selon mme hayden bon
nom la guerre n'est pas y réunir
immédiat mais n'est pas inévitable on
peut dire que les tambours bat de plus
en plus fort que les tensions montent et
qu'on a un peu ce ping-pong que vous
avez évoqué le négociations au petit
déjeuner tout d'un coup au déjeuner et
plus de tensions nées des origines d'une
douche écossaise ou une douche
ukrainienne très forte bon mais pour
l'instant tant qu' il ya des
escarmouches effectivement dans le
donbass mais pour l'instant en tous les
cas aucun soldat russe n'a tiré qu'un
soldat ukrainien donc ce n'est pas la
guerre au sens premier du terme et il
faut reconnaître le mérite à certains
dirigeants au permet aux américains
aussi tellement russe pour l'instant
c'est toujours la solution diplomatique
et privilèges cette fois elle est
difficile on n'est pas d'accord sur les
termes cette solution mais pour l'un
centrica il n'y a pas de guerre même si
effectivement on la craint très fort est
alors l'une des dernières infos de cette
fin d'après midi un civil tués par un
bombardement séparatiste dans la région
de dounia tu sais le gouvernement
régional le gouverneur régional qui dit
ça c'est pas le même degré qu'est ce que
vous avez évoquant ses pas un soldat
russe qui tué un soldat canadien où la
mer sont malheureusement des
escarmouches dans le donbass des
violations du cessez-le-feu il y en a
régulièrement elles ont fait des
dizaines voire des centaines de morts
depuis la signature des accords de minsk
mais on en est si finalement à des
combats internes au sein de l'ukraine ce
n'est pas pareil que une guerre entre la
russie et l'ukraine deux pays et vient
de la guerre entre deux pays européens
ça n'a pas existé il ya eu bien sûr la
guerre du kosovo en 99 et une petite
guerre entre la turquie et la grèce en
74 75 mais quand même sinon on vers bien
les conséquences que cela pourrait avoir
oui tout à fait pour aller dans ce sens
que 10 à pascal boniface il ya des
escarmouches qui sont de plus en plus
grave est cette après midi on a eu des
accusations du côté russe à savoir qu'un
tir de mortier il serait arrivé du côté
de russell frontières sur la poste se
feront tient même ce resto et donc c'est
grave ça veut dire qu'on a l'impression
que les russie vladimir poutine cherche
tous les par tous les moyens a
finalement justifier une éventuelle
intervention militaire ces escargots
sont très graves est en soi une montée
de la pression on se demande jusqu'où ça
va même utilisé le terme de génocide oui
à propos des populations russophones du
dombass et les mots ont un sens quand
même donc effectivement quand par le
génocide on irait peut justifier
l'intervention militaire pour l'emmener
reviendra sur la manipulation de
l'information parce que c'est un vrai
enjeu galia ackerman est-ce que selon
vous la dire poutine peut sortir de ce
de cette crise sans une prise
territoriales voyez ce que veut dire
même minime
non je crois que je vous service était
très difficile de comprendre quels sont
les objectifs de vladimir poutine dans
cette tension dans cette concentration
de troupes qui dure depuis plusieurs
mois il ya
encore un facteur dont on n'a pas du
tout parlé c'est que l'on vient d'avoir
des manoeuvres conjointes russo
biélorusses en biélorussie et je
souligne un parmi ces manoeuvres il y
avait aussi des lancements de missiles
qui n'avaient pas d'ogives nucléaires
mais ce sont des missiles à double
emploi ils peuvent être utilisés
avec des têtes conventionnelle et avec
des têtes nucléaires
maintenant ces manoeuvres devaient être
terminés hier
et ils ont été prolongées il ya eu un
communiqué disant que vu la situation
explosive en ukraine danger le temps et
c'est rare les troupes vont rester là
jusqu'à ce que ce soit utile
c'est-à-dire peut-être vitam aeternam et
on voit que tout le monde pense à
l'ukraine alors que entre temps les
troupes russes se sont installés en
biélorussie et il y aura peut-être aussi
dans le cadre de cet état d'union une
nucléarisation de la biélorussie bon à
suivre dans les prochains jours jour est
qu'on fasse ensemble un gros plan sur la
difficulté d'informer sur un conflit
comme celui là et sur ce qui se passe en
ukraine on est avec thomas huchon qui
est avec nous en duplex bonsoir thomas
husson spécialistes sortant d un fox des
faits que nous du complotisme et des
manipulations j'ai envie de dire que
cette guerre des nerfs ces termes qu'on
a décidé d'employer ce soir c'est aussi
un défi pour nous journalistes mais
aussi pour tous les citoyens qui
partagent des vidéos sur les sur les
médias sociaux il ya eu plusieurs cas de
false flag alors est-ce que vous pouvez
nous expliquer ce que c'est qu'un false
flag fault line c'est ce qu'on appelle
une opération sous faux drapeau ça a été
utilisé comme une stratégie militaire à
diverses moment de l'histoire je
laisserai vovo spécialiste de la
géopolitique vous donner des exemples le
plus précis mais la notion de false flag
elle a aussi été détournée par
les gens qui croient aux théories du
complot qui vont utiliser
cet élément qui a pu exister dans
l'histoire comme un argument pour dire
que ce qu'on nous raconte à la
télévision n'est pas la réalité alors
par exemple les attentats ne sont pas le
fait de terroristes mais le fait de
gouvernements des provocations à la
frontière sont le fait bien entendu et
bien de deux personnalités payer par les
puissants pour nous manipuler et en fait
cette notion de force langue qui est
encore une fois on le rappelle a été une
vraie stratégie militaire et qui sera
peut-être encore une vraie stratégie
militaire et bien est utilisé par les
complotistes pour nier la réalité et on
a eu un exemple très récent un don john
bass justement la semaine dernière oui
alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé
justement c'est des images sur
lesquelles parce qu'il y en a eu
plusieurs donc des images sur lesquelles
on a rajouté des coups de feu mais sauf
que il était bien une autre
c'est même encore mieux que ça mais
c'est c'est quelque chose qui est
d'ailleurs peut-être va va changer un
petit peu notre vision de l'ogre russe
qui serait tout puissant et qui ne
ferait jamais d'erreurs il ya eu
vendredi une vidéo postée par un leader
séparatiste
pro russe denis pucci line il condamne
vendredi donc dans l'après-midi le
bombardement en tout cas des
bombardements ukrainien sur les
provinces occupée par les russes il se
trouve que la technologie a plein de
défauts mais elle a dans ce cas précis
un gros avantage le gros avantage c'est
qu'il y a quand vous transmettez une
vidéo un certain nombre de métadonnées
d'informations qui sont liées aux
fichiers en lui-même et notamment la
date de la création de cette vidéo et le
problème c'est que cette vidéo supposé
tournée en direct vendredi pour dénoncer
le comportement l'agression des forces
du craignent n eh ben elle est
malheureusement daté du 16 février donc
de mardi dans ces métadonnées ce qui
montre bien que déjà il s'agit d'un
mensonge que donc cette vidéo a été
enregistrée deux jours avant les
supposée agression ce qui laisse penser
que c'était pas exactement ça qui se
passait mais surtout ça montre bien que
et bien y compris peut-être ce que l'on
imagine comme des spécialistes de l'as
des informations numériques peuvent
faire une erreur aussi basiques que de
ne pas modifier les dates ou supprimé
les métadonnées associées un fichier et
faire en sorte qu'un un adolescent un
peu féru de technologie puisse
déconstruire un mensonge de cet ordre un
dernier mot thomas husson peut-être un
conseil aux téléspectateurs qu'ils
utilisent les médias sociaux il est il
est vrai pendant cette guerre mais il
est vrai général faire attention à ce
qu'on a ce qu'on partage à ce compte
twitter alors c'est certain que si vous
voulez thomas qu'on est un petit conseil
qui résonne un peu à ce qu'on avait dans
notre enfance vous souvenez on nous
disait qu'il faut tourner sept fois sa
langue dans la bouche avant de parler eh
bien peut-être que tourner sept fois la
main au dessus du smartphone avant de
cliquer ou de partager c'est pas une
idée débile le problème c'est que 60%
des gens qui partagent des contenus sur
les réseaux sociaux ne les ont pas lu en
entier avant de les partager ça dit
quand même encore l'ampleur du travail à
faire non pas pour lutter contre la
désinformation
mais pour freiner la diffusion de choses
qui ne sont pas lus par les gens qui ne
partagent merci thomas husson voilà un
peu de pédagogie savoir si un jour du
bien anti fait que nous livre
indispensable pour démêler le vrai du
faux c'est aux éditions first petite
question pascal boniface là dessus le
département d'état prend les devants il
dit que la russie prépare une fausse
vidéo avec de vrais cadavres censé
servir de preuve d'une attaque de kiev
alors est ce qu'on peut croire les
américains moi en lisant ça me si oui
alors on a tous en tête le souvenir de
de l'irak des prétendues armes chimiques
de saddam hussein enfin bref dans un
conflit comme celui là qui croit on sait
que quand la guerre commence la première
victime c'est la vérité est que chacun
essaye de désinformer de manipuler et
qui a pas le monopole de la
désinformation contre le monopole de la
vertu la jussie c'est l'exemple que vous
rappelez dans tous les esprits on se
rappelle également de la mère éplorée
qui disait que saddam hussein avait
débranché les couveuses au koweit alors
saddam hussein était sincèrement pas un
verre d'un sympathique mais dès qu'ils
aient l'opération de guerre il ya de la
propagande heureusement il ya les moyens
aussi de lutter entre cela et il ya des
moyens effectivement 20,2 vérifier et de
dévoiler les supercheries et quand c'est
trop grossier comme cela s'est vite
connu ça se retourne contre leurs
auteurs donc il ya la tentation des
informations mais attention si vous
n'êtes pas vu pas pris ça va mais si
vous êtes pris la main dans le sac et
bien c'est toutes vos communications qui
vient s'effondrer et qui vient perdre
votre faire perdre votre crédibilité
quant à l' expertise du département
d'état ou des services américains ça
fait quand même quelques jours voire
quelques semaines qui nous annonce un
durcissement ou la guerre ni pour demain
on n'est toujours pas mais on n'y est
toujours pas mais ça ça peut être une
stratégie oui martin geniez c'est à dire
que oui il le fait d'annoncer à c'est
une façon de dents peut-être dans je ne
sais pas d'empêcher poutine ou 2 2 de
lui mettre des bâtons dans les roues je
ne sais pas si ça peut avoir un effet
dissuasif mais ce qui est terrible c'est
que vous savez la communication trop de
communication tue la communication ça
fait des semaines que joe biden nous
annonce l'invasion le lendemain de
l'ukraine par la russie dont tout le
monde se prépare psychologiquement il
essayait c'est la guerre c'est sûr des
américains comme émission ils sont
sérieux ils ont tous les toutes les
informations qui émanent de leurs
services de renseignement ils sont prêts
manifestement ils sont prêts mais je ne
vois pas où est l'utilité de prévoir et
d'annoncés l'invasion de vladimir
poutine alors que finalement la décision
lui impute à lui seul c'est lui seul
sait ce qu'il va faire je ne vois pas
très bien l'utilité de faire cela ça tue
la communication c'est une préparation
psychologique j'en veux dire c'est un
peu comme la chèvre de monsieur seguin
attention voilà le loup afin de
l'appeler on dit
pierre et le loup mais
le loup il arrive et puis on le croit
plus plutôt que ça tue la communication
mais l'objectif des états unis c'est de
nous préparer psychologiquement à cette
guerre de préparer le monde à des
mesures de rétorsion très importantes
lors alors que cette invasion n'a
toujours pas eu lieu et donc c'est vrai
que ça peut être contre-productif
d'annoncer une invasion qui m'envahit
revenir aux sanctions je vous redonner
la parole pascal mais je gagnais
ackermann je vais vous regardez beaucoup
la télévision russe évidemment depuis
plusieurs semaines et particulièrement
ces derniers jours que disent les hits
et russes en ce moment que voit que
voient les compatriotes de vladimir
poutine les compatriotes voient
notamment
la fuite des habitants donc de ces deux
républiques autoproclamées parce que les
dirigeants de ces républiques ont
demandé à la russie d'accueillir les
réfugiés et ya à peu près sept cent
cinquante mille personnes dans le dos
parce qu'ils sont porteurs de passeports
russes
ça c'était une politique délibérée
depuis depuis un bon moment et donc
maintenant la russie censé défendre la
population russe citoyen russe d'une
basse et donc on a simultanément on
annonce la mobilise action des hommes et
le départ vers la russie de femmes
d'enfants et de vieux
rien n'a été préparé pour les accueillir
néanmoins il ya déjà plusieurs dizaines
de milliers de personnes qui sont
parties en abandonnant tout donc
clairement on se prépare quand même à
une action militaire
je crois que ça fait partie de toute
cette
technique pour aboutir à l'annexion en
tout cas la reconnaissance de
l'indépendance de ces deux républiques
que maintenant la russie va défendre
avec son armée est peut-être
parallèlement essayé de
poser une sorte d'ultimatum couteau sur
la gorge en avançant par exemple via la
biélorussie
vers le kiev sais pas c'est possible
sont peut-être même des fantaisies mai
mais s'est défoncé par pure nacional
yoko et et
le ton général c'est que les accords de
minsk de toute façon ne peuvent pas être
les conditions ne peuvent pas être
exécutée
donc maintenant il est l'heure d'aider
nos frères le peuple du donbass voilà on
montre qu'on commence à justifier de
plus en plus appelés en intervention et
justes et encore une chose et on montre
aussi des images des soi disant attaque
de l'armée kényane qui a été demandée en
fait de faire preuve de la plus grande
retenue justement pour ne pas attiser
les actions militaires mais ce qu'on
montre est totalement bidon comme ce tir
qui a abouti sur des gardes frontières
le poste de garde frontière dans la
région de rostov
quand vous voyez c'est une cabane
abandonnée dans les champs et ça a été
démenti par le pouvoir ukrainien yulia
intervenir pascal ensuite on revient la
diplomatie est vivement sur le lard mis
sous l'éteignoir s inquiète un peu parce
qu'ils disent si à force de sonner
l'alarmé si un jour il ya des règles
pressions chinoises contre nous personne
ne va le croire et donc il faut arrêter
d'être alarmiste ainsi et on voit que le
président ukrainien hélène ce qui lui
est dément et dit non non la situation
est sous contrôle à quelques pourquoi
cette stratégie d'une part ça resserre
qu'à une unité du monde occidental et
tout le monde dit l'otan n'a jamais été
aussi puissant rappelez vous il ya deux
ans et il manu macron dit l'otan est en
état de mort cérébrale là maintenant
tout le monde resserrent les rangs il va
y avoir certainement une augmentation
des dépenses militaires des pays
européens ça va donc faire des achats
d'armes américaines et puis si
l'alliance n'a pas lieu byden pourra
dire grâce à notre fermeté mais d'avant
puis villa et donc des deux côtés il
peut gagner par cet alarmisme et c'est
aussi un peu le jeu de du président
français
mathieu est ce qu il a marqué des points
selon vous dans sa gestion de la crise
ukrainienne l'histoire n'est pas finie
mais moi je dirais plutôt que oui
c'était un sacré pari est un pari à
double tranchant de jouer comme ça sur
la scène diplomatique
international évidemment parce que ça
pouvait tout aussi bien le hic c'est que
ces resserrements parlant d'égal à égal
avec dieu avec les grands de ce monde
que le marginaliser s'il était passé
pour un figurant ou une marionnette de
vladimir poutine vous que ces gens là il
a visiblement confondu vitesse et
précipitation dans l'annoncé de ce ce
sommet de la dernière chance mais
globalement il est allé à moscou
globalement il aura tenté jusqu'au bout
de trouver une solution diplomatique
d'une certaine façon qu'importe le
résultat pour l'opinion publique
française
il aura essayé il aura été écouté même
s'il n'a pas été forcément même s'il
n'aura pas été forcément entendu est un
bon signe en fait c'est de voir ce que
disent ses rivaux à la présidentielle
parce que là pour le coup il se trouve
un peu fort dépourvu vous prenez valérie
pécresse par exemple qui appelle à une
fermeté d'acier vis-à-vis de la
demi-heure poutine qui montre qu'elle
parle russe pour appuyer son propos mais
qui ne convainc pas grand monde pas plus
que les appels aux non alignement de la
france 2 jean-luc mélenchon ou les
appellent à la neutralité de l'ukraine
de marine le pen ou les appelle un peu
plus alambiqués d'eric zemmour qui le
renvoie la faute à l'otan tout en
demandant à vladimir poutine de
respecter la souveraineté de son voisin
ces trois là au fond ils ont un peu du
mal à masquer leurs tropismes pro russe
qui fait que s'il admire on commence à
attaquer à venir l'ukraine et que la
guerre devient sanglante ça va finir par
se voir foncer difficile d'attaquer une
position de médiateur celle qu'a choisi
emmanuel macron comme me le confier à un
membre de l'équipe de valérie pécresse
il ya dix jours c'est dur pour eux de
voir le président sortant discuter avec
les grands de ce monde un peu ça fait un
peut pas discuter avec les adultes
pendant que les enfants se disputent la
maison quoi alors la crise craignent nl
certes peut-être l'image du président
mais elle complique aussi son entrée en
campagne oui ça c'est le deuxième effet
il est moins bon qu'un président sortant
d'une certaine façon s'est mis lui-même
dans la seringue en déclarant la voix du
nord où sont nés le 1er février dernier
qu'il attendait que soit passée deux
pics de crise le pic de la crise
sanitaire et le pic de la crise et
ukrainienne pour le pic de la crise
sanitaire on y est pour le pic de la
crise craignant manifestement non
c'était une phrase imprudente parce que
en fait elle visait juste a justifié son
choix tactiques tardif de se déclarer
mais la voilà qui pourrait comprendre
qu'il se déclare par exemple demain
alors que soi-disant de on est au pic de
la crise l'ukrainienne par ailleurs
d'une façon générale si la stature
internationale c'est un atout
supplémentaire dans la manche de chaque
président sortant 1 par rapport à ses
rivaux c'est pas non plus un talisman ça
n'empêche pas de perdre quant au supposé
manque de stature des concurrences qui
n'ont jamais été présidents ben c'est
pas non plus un handicap insurmontable
comme le disait autrefois françois
hollande ont fait président le jour où
on est président mais surtout le
rayonnement de la france à l'étranger où
la place de la france dans le monde pour
leur rappeler ça fait pas partie des
premières préoccupations des français
cours le regrette ou non dans cette
élection comme dans aucune élection
présidentielle vème république merci
mathieu la diplomatie - évidemment elle
est toujours à l'oeuvre patrick martin
geniez le
la réunion qui est officiel c'est celle
des deux chefs de la diplomatie entend
public année et seriez lavrov ça doit se
passer je dis oui
maintenant ça nous garantit pas qu'il
ait pas
un déclenchement avant ce qu'on peut en
non l'expérience de ces dernières
semaines montrent qu' il peut y avoir
toutes les réunions diplomatiques
ministériel à quelque niveau que ce soit
ça n'empêchera rien du tout alors il y
aura deux secrétaires d'état américain
qui va rencontrer monsieur la vraie
misère c'est un russe on va monsieur le
drian qui va pas légalement avec
monsieur lavrov on a la conférence
l'organisation sur la sécurité et la
coopération en europe qui se réunit avec
le format a3 avec la russie et l'ukraine
il ya de multiples autres rencontres le
premier ministre britannique qui appelle
aussi donc le chance de le président
russe et le chancelier allemand qui doit
rencontrer également il a avant une
commune de varen une communication
téléphonique également avec vladimir
poutine donc tout ça c'est intéressant
on est toujours dans le registre
diplomatique mais ça n'empêchera pas
quoi qu'il en soit bladimir poutine
d'envahir l'ukraine ou peut-être de nos
basses il souhaite lui la diplomatie est
au service de sa force militaire sa
force nationale donc effectivement eu
d'accord pour discuter mais il ne veut
pas bouger de ces lignes rouges on parle
de l'ukraine au final on pourrait
peut-être dire que l'ukraine c'est pas
ton sac il intéresse finalement enfin
c'est un des éléments de sa stratégie ce
qui l'intéresse aussi de redessiner
complètement l' architecture de la
sécurité en europe ça aussi c'est
quelque chose qui l'intéresse il a parlé
d'un traité même les états unis ont
parlé éventuellement de la traiter d'une
transparence sur le mouvement des
troupes sur le fait qu'on ne devait pas
y avoir d'armes nucléaires en europe de
l'est et on a bien vu qu'il cherche des
alliances très puissante à l'étranger
notamment avec la chine tout cela parce
que enfin en fin de compte il ya
l'ukraine mais il ya aussi la sécurité
en europe il considère à tort selon moi
que le temps est une force militaire
agressive alors qu'elle a toujours eu un
caractère défensif et on à 199 un bon
jeu pour l'allemand on apprend à
l'instant une déclaration de vladimir
poutine annoncé à la télévision russe
imminente donc dans la soirée on verra
bien sur quel pied du mur poutine va si
j'ose dire nous faire danser parce que
voilà c'est quand même on n'oublie pas
les populations dans cette région de
l'ukraine je voulais en venir aux
sanctions économiques et vous propose
d'entendre une réaction celle du
ministre français des affaires
étrangères il était auditionné ici au
sénat le 16 février on écoute le paquet
des sanctions est assez significatif il
sera nous sommes prêts
c'est la fois financier et économique
technique nous sommes prêts
c'est des sanctions d'une autre ampleur
que celles qui ont pu être mises en
oeuvre dans le passé
et c'est intègre beaucoup d'aspects tout
en précisant par ailleurs que dans les
discussions que nous avons avec les
américains il est entre européens
comprend aussi les précautions de
résilience
pour éviter pour des sanctions qui nous
reviennent en boomerang les sanctions
occidentales la russie en a rien à
pardon mais c'est pas moi qui le
dit c'est l ambassadeur russe en suède
11 février dernier c'est vraiment c'est
du bluff comme celle de alors non il
sait ça va bien sur les appendices a
atteint aussi malheureusement les
européens donc en fait contrôler
sanction par rapport à la russie qui est
un marché la france est le premier
employeur étranger en russie il ya 160 8
français qui travaillent pour les
entreprises russes pas besoin de 105
villes russes qui travaillent peu grise
française en russie donc effectivement
on à cancon assez les sanctions après
l'annexion de la crimée la russie a
réagi la filière porcine à filière
laitière ont été impactés alors ça va
les atteindre mais ils ont des réserves
économique assez importante et surtout
ils en profitent pour essayer de
développer ceux qui se les sanctions
viennent parfois paradoxalement renforcé
un pays en leur faisant développer des
choses qui ne dirait pas auparavant
alors ça c'est intéressant effectivement
gagné ackermann c'est à dire que
la société et l'économie surtout russes
et plus résiliente d'ailleurs qu'elle
s'est adapté aux sanctions précédentes
et donc il ya des produits qui n'étaient
pas disponibles et qu'elle sait qu'elle
s'est mise à fabriquer elle même est ce
qu'on peut dire ça écoutez c'est vrai
pour l'agriculture parce que je rappelle
quand même que face aux sanctions
occidentales la russie a adopté des
contres sanction qui notamment en
interdisaient l'importation en russie de
plusieurs denrées alimentaires dont
l'effet des du saucisson des différents
clients des produits laitiers des
fromages de ces trains est en effet là
les fermiers russes ont développé des
des filières qu'ils n'ont pas la même
qualité que nos produits à nous il y
avait notamment beaucoup de beurre avec
l'huile de palme et setra
mémé est la population russe parce que
c'est ça aussi qui nous intéresse
puisque on a démarré ce débat et vous
nous l'avez dit en disant que l'ayant
contini il s'adresse d'abord évidemment
à son opinion comme tous les chefs
d'états d'ailleurs la population russe
des sanctions économiques elles elles
les ressens est l'écrin est ce que vous
diriez là dessus il les ressent bien sûr
hélas comme elle a ressenti les contres
sanction de 2014
mais là il s'agit deux choses qui
peuvent en effet frapper assez
lourdement la russie certains pensent
qu'il y aura l'interdiction d'accès au
swift ou d'autres disent qu'il n'y aura
pas de swift dans le paquet descend
alors il faut expliquer ses gazoducs
c'est ça
j'avais mal entendu maintenant c'est le
système bancaire à chaque fois que wii
wii fit nous fondant virement vous le
faites par le système swift
ensuite il ya probablement des sanctions
contre les banques les plus importantes
banques russes en probablement
l'impossibilité de traiter avec les
dollars
il ya probablement les limitations de
l'importation de certaines technologies
et de deux pièces vitales comme les
semi-conducteurs etc est-ce que cela
aura une incidence très lourde oh non on
ne sait pas les les occidentaux pensent
que oui mais je pense aussi que la
russie a quand même un allié magistral
comme la chine et que la chine notamment
l'aidera à surmonter les sanctions alors
je reprends la main excusez-moi de vous
deux vous interromps mais quand on parle
de sanctions économiques patrick martin
joly il ya aussi la le revers de la
médaille dire que si on parle par
exemple de l'europe et c'est vrai je
voulais venir ou au gaz russe était on
est aussi enfin nous peut grâce au
nucléaire mais les allemands très
dépendants du gaz russe donc c'est
évidemment un des pièces de l'échiquier
et qu'on hésite à jouer
avant déclencher des sanctions
économiques à l'aide évidemment moi
j'entendais la vice-présidente
américaine kamala harris ce samedi à
munich à la conférence sur la sécurité
dire que ces sanctions seraient sans
précédent c'est à dire viserait non
seulement comme vous l'avez dit le
système financier international mais
également les proches du kremlin les
grandes entreprises les banques et voir
la dîmière poutine lui-même donc là
c'est un élément mais il peut prendre
des mesures de rétorsion contre l'europe
nous dépendons je crois hauteur de 40%
du gaz naturel de la russie mais ça peut
aller bien plus haut pour l'allemagne
j'ai lu des chiffres comme entre cinq
ans 55% de dépendance de l'allemagne
vis-à-vis du gaz naturel à tel point que
les etats-unis ont dit en appeler
d'autres pays a éventuellement alimenter
l'europe en gaz naturel même au japon
j'ai même vu que le japon se préparer
éventuellement envoyer du gaz naturel en
europe si donc nous sommes très
dépendants et donc sur ce point quelque
chose de tout à fait symptomatique
c'est que le fameux gazoduc dans scream
2 doit être mis en oeuvre dans les
semaines qui viennent il n'ya plus que
l'autorisation de l'autorité de
régulation allemande pour donner son
autorisation et de le mettre en oeuvre
et olaf scholz rappelez vous a jamais
voulu dire très clairement s'il mettrait
un terme à ce projet ou pas même à la
maison blanche lorsque joe biden a dit
nous mettrons un terme au nord stream 2
est bien le chancelier a refusé de
confirmer qu'on termine au reste à l'est
un peu moins de cinq minutes sur le
le risque militaire aussi pour la russie
pascal boniface il ya un vrai risque mur
il n'y a pas si facile ou non
effectivement et le plan américain
disant que les russes iront jusqu à kiev
pour mettre un gouvernement à leurs
mains mais comment ils vont tenir cela
on a vu que quand même récemment les
pays qui ont gagné d hier ont eu du mal
à rester sur place de l'irak à
l'afghanistan en passant par le mali est
là les ukrainiens autant en crimée 7 est
relativement facile puisque la
population souhaitait devenir russe
s'est pas du tout le cas en ukraine et
encore moins inquiet vous le sentiment
national s'est forgée contre la russie
et si les russes veulent perdre la craie
la l'ukraine pour des générations c'est
ce qu'il faut faire don admettons qu'il
fasse la guerre qu'il la gagne vous
croyez que il les ukrainiens vont dire
voilà on a perdu la guerre on va
accepter cela il fera des morts tous les
jours et poutine il faut bien qu'on ne
l'est pas assez et me renverse un
président pro russe le point de départ
du conflit c'est ça voilà et puis par
ailleurs poutine même si saint pée
autorités il a quand même une population
qui n'a pas envie de voir des cercueils
rentrer tous les jours la jeunesse le
décompte des morts on a du sens aux
repris donc il ya quand même je pense
que le ce risque là ce risque sanitaire
le risque du décompte des morts est un
frein bien plus puissant encore que les
menaces de sanctions et bien sûr que le
droit international mais gagner
ackermann le la résistance ukrainienne
on voit beaucoup d'image de population
qui se prépare qui ressorte des fusils
qui s'entraîne et c'est comment on peut
la mesurer cette résistance c'est très
difficile à mesurer mais je crois que la
russie a pris vraiment une fausse route
à partir de fin 2013 début 2014
elle aurait dû rester amicale envers
l'ukraine parce que c'est vrai que ce
sont deux peuples historiquement très
proche proche culturellement avec
beaucoup de liens entre les familles
russes et ukrainiennes beaucoup de
mariages mixtes et c'est rare mais en
huit ans de la guerre dans le dôme bas
c'est après l'annexion de la crimée
les ukrainiens sont de plus en plus
hostile à la russie et je pense qu'en
effet on a vu des échanges sur les
réseaux sociaux absolument incroyable
comme une nuit dame de kharkov qui qui
dit moi je peux pas partir j'ai un chat
mais j'ai aussi un vieux fusil que je
vais résister c'est pathétique mais ça
montre l'état d'esprit de la population
oui donc la population qui peut et on
peut s'attendre à ce qu'elle à ce
qu'elle résiste est ce que on peut
peut-être terminée là dessus patrick et
là martin jonny est ce que l'objectif de
poutine c'est de replacer un président
pro russe au pouvoir vous dit vous
parliez tout à l'heure de de rumeurs de
coup d'état
oui enfin c'est ça fait partie des
hypothèses oui c'est à dire on pourrait
envoyer l'ue l'ukraine et mettra pro
poutine à kiev cela entraîna
effectivement des éliminations physiques
de tous les dirigeants à nouvelle à
nouvel état qui serait pro poutine en
effet ça fait partie de cette
possibilité une autre possibilité c'est
de fait on va voir ce soir ce qu'il en
est de reconnaître officiellement les
républiques séparatistes du dombass et
avoir un pied bien ancré au sein de
l'ukraine à travers ces républiques pour
finalement limité d'abord violé
l'intégrité territoriale du cren et bien
sûr violé son sa souveraineté merci
beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir participé
à ce débat je rappelle les titres de vos
livres
pascal boniface commence avec vous 50
idées reçues sur l'état du monde aux
éditions armand colin galia ackerman
votre livre régiment immortel la guerre
sacrée de poutine ces premiers parallèle
et patrick martin geniez vers une
nouvelle gouvernance mondiale aux
éditions studyrama merci encore merci à
tous les 300 ce public